so you're planning a road trip across
the united states
well you'll definitely need this
and this and maybe this
you might see this or even this but
mostly you'll see a lot of these
these signs tell you where to go or
where you are
but most of them have something else in
common
their typeface highway gothic is
carefully composed to guide you to your
destination
without distracting you but for the past
decade
another typeface has been trying to take
its place
highway gothic was created in 1948.
right around the time highway started
crisscrossing the united states
it came out of an initiative at the
california department of transportation
to develop a clearer and more
legible standard for highway signs of
the six fonts or variations they
developed
this version became the highway standard
the spacing is specified to be quite
loose and that's something that
that is a big help in viewing at very
long distances
[Music]
those angled tops to the letters that
you see in the alpha t
that was the solution that appeared in
highway gothic to
differentiate shapes it becomes you know
important in states like illinois
where you have cap eye and lowercase l
and you need to
be unambiguous about what's what soon
after its creation
every highway in america was plastered
with highway gothic
but by the late 1980s with the
introduction of new reflective sign
materials
highway gothic started to have problems
specifically with something called
halation
pallation is when light spreads beyond
its proper boundaries
creating a halo effect it's that glow
you see around a bright object on a tv
screen
like in the scene and once upon a time
in hollywood right there in the upper
right
elderly drivers specifically were having
trouble reading these signs at night as
lower case letters like e
a and s started blurring into o's
the counter of the e that's really very
tight there even
before you point a headlight at us at
night even in broad daylight
that would blur together but by this
time a potential
solution was on its way by the end of
the 90s
font designers and a crew of researchers
from penn state and 3m
had created the second typeface we see
on highway signs
clearview at first glance
clearview and highway gothic look pretty
similar but when you look closer
you can see how different they really
are decisions like
the counter of the a and the counter of
the e those internal
spaces are made much larger because the
a and the u
they trend towards this kind of squarish
shape
i suspect that was done to further
reinforce the
enlargement of these internal shapes the
hybrid gothic stumbles quite a lot
if you take a close look at the
lowercase s it does seem like
one side of the curve is arguing with
the other as it
goes through that pretty complex track
that has to follow d and
s clearview tries to fix that by
widening the spaces
opening up these letters can help
mitigate the problem inflation
and during testing clearview showed a 16
improvement in recognition over highway
gothic at night
which meant that drivers that were
driving at 60 miles per hour would have
an extra one to two seconds to make a
decision based on sign information
in 2004 the federal highway
administration granted interim approval
for clearview to be used on an optional
basis
mostly when old signs needed to be
replaced
around 30 states adopted clearview in
some form
the resulting mix of signs has caused
some confusion and further studies have
called into question
clearview's improved legibility
specifically on lighter colored signs
and its more stylized number forms
one study from texas a m in 2014 found
that clearview's legibility was not
statistically different than highway
gothics
i think in purely mechanical
i would say clearview is more successful
because
it does create a more even texture than
highway gothic
there's something very distinctly
american
about highway gothic and it is a bit
blunt
and stumbling and loud and
clearview is almost in that respect too
polished
today the fhwa still allows the use of
clearview in some cases
but they make no recommendation or
endorsement of the clearview letter
style
which means if you go out on the highway
right now there's a mix
two fonts that ultimately do the job
they're designed to do
get you where you're going with the
least confusion
[Music]
[Music]
you